I just want to apologize and say that
I'm so so sorry for all of these
theories I never meant to hurt anyone I
never meant to offend anyone didn't mean
to scare anyone so sorry I'm also really
sorry that I didn't bring any Kleenex
because my nose is running like a mofo
right now so anyone who I've ever
offended what was that
hello Internet
welcome to film theory the show that's
like unsolved mysteries for the 21st
century of things people haven't thought
about since the late 90s let's talk
about the Blair Witch Project
since the 2016 sequel to the movie is
currently either in theaters or has been
forgotten by history as a bland horror
cash-in by the time that you watch this
video but the original was something
special because it was one of the first
movies that took advantage of the
Internet as a viral marketing tool Blair
which came out the age before you could
use Snopes to reveal that all those
memes Uncle Joe posts up on Facebook are
made up so when Buzz started going
around that this found footage movie was
real found footage a lot of people were
fooled some of the family members of the
actors even got sympathy cards in the
mail and you can't really blame them for
being cool either the makers of the
movie made a fake documentary about the
disappearance of the actors and set up
websites with information about the
names and places they made up for the
movie I'm here today to clear things up
once and for all tell you that not only
is the Blair Witch Project to work of
fiction but that the Blair Witch herself
is a fiction within that fiction Thrones
movie were led to believe that these
young filmmakers Josh Heather and Mike
are being terrorized by some evil force
in the woods bazoom ibly the Blair Witch
but after studying the evidence it
becomes clear that none of the events
are actually supernatural nope the whole
thing is just a setup for the two guys
Josh and Mike to murder Heather I know I
know that is a huge claim to make and
I'm sure that a lot of you don't believe
me but let me lay down the evidence so
you can judge for yourself it's been a
couple years since you've seen the Blair
Witch Project here's a refresher Heather
is
film maker looking to do a documentary
on the mysterious urban legends
surrounding the town of Burkittsville
Maryland formerly named Blair she
recruits her friend Josh to run the
camera Josh brings along his friend Mike
to handle sound now Heather and Mike
have never met before as evidenced by
Heather saying I guess when we see the
first shots of him leaving his house
this is confirmed by Heather's journal
released in its entirety online as part
of that viral marketing campaign we're
on page 2 she mentions not knowing him
meanwhile were never quite clear on the
relationship between Josh and Heather
sure the movie reveals that Josh and
Heather definitely know each other but
there's a little more to it than that
the initial concept for the movie had
Josh as Heather's ex-boyfriend and even
though that didn't really make it into
the events that we see on-screen
Heather's diary does give us some hints
about their history on page 13 as they
prep to go into the woods
she writes quote Josh doesn't listen to
me at all and he's supposed to be my
friend Mike is more respectful and I
don't know dick about him a few days
later early on in their trip into the
woods she writes on page 16 Josh well
josh is always a surprise
so displayed thinking their friends
clearly Josh isn't agonistic to Heather
even before they're out to the woods and
things start to go wrong and to make
matters stranger neither Mike nor Josh
is getting paid for their work on the
movie it's never mentioned in the movie
itself but Heather's diary fills in the
details on both page 12 and on page 20
these guys are working for free on a
movie that will have them hiking deep
into the wilderness in the cold and rain
all while carrying heavy film equipment
remember this was set in 1994 faint
filming this thing on their iPhones and
it's not like Heather is some brilliant
director many of whom remain either on
this hill or in the town below
maybe josh is doing it because he's a
friend but Mike spending a week with a
stranger pro bono it's just odd because
some of the things Josh says on the
first day of the shoot are just
uncomfortable so we all like cut our
fingers open and bleed on it ha ha ha
cool joke bro yeah let's let's all bleed
on the clapboard but assume for a minute
josh did want to kill Heather for some
reason Heather says on tape
so this project definitely gives them
the opportunity and in order to pull it
off without getting caught he enlists
Mike for help but obviously that's
speculation we need some evidence to
incriminate Mike and Josh and their
behavior on tape gives us some pretty
big red flags first Heather is the one
who plans the whole excursion and based
off Mike's admission that the map looks
like Greek to him this is Greek to me we
would expect Heather to be leading the
way but in almost every shot Mike and
Josh are walking ahead of her guiding
the group as if they already know where
they're going and that's just the tip of
the iceberg a huge chunk in the middle
of the movie is dedicated to arguing
over their map Matt Matt Matt Matt man a
sequence that gets made fun of by
everyone from cinemasins
to honest trailers because of how long
it goes on however if you track the
chain of events in the map hand offs you
see that something here is definitely
not right let me walk you through it the
group is successfully filmed that their
to desired location Xander headed back
to the car
Heather begins to use the map to guide
them along the shortest possible route
back to where they parked however Mike
and Josh start to cause a commotion over
nothing looking the same as when they
first hiked out I don't remember a
portion of this one
as Heather correctly explains that was
the most direct way to hit our two
locations now this is the most draft way
back to the car and it makes logical
sense it's simple geometry point one
point two hypotenuse according to
Heather they're about two hours away
from the car and she remains confident
that they can get there yet it's the
guys who are unsatisfied outright
refusing to walk Josh then demands to
see the math now we don't see the
handoff as they cut to them camping for
the night but the next morning the map
has gone missing with Heather convinced
that she gave it to Josh saying it over
and over I gave you back the map Heather
I gave you back the map josh of course
denies it and yet based on the footage
we saw from the night before josh was
the most likely person to last have it
based on him demanding to see it over
and over give me the map after give me
the map but the map gone tensions are
obviously high and despite Heather
trying to get them to continue moving in
the direction they were headed it's a
Mike mr. it's all Greek to me who
determines which way they'll walk I who
up to this point has shown no enthusiasm
for guiding the team it's another odd
decision so now consider the following
you're lost in the woods for days with
strange noises happening at night and no
map despite all of this shortly after
the map blow up Mike and Josh start
joking around like nothing happened can
we keep going please
an emotional shift so unwarranted and so
abrupt Heather takes notice and get
suspicious specifically calling out not
you learn to get to the car and this
just seems like you guys are having just
a little bit too much fun tonight they
jump forward a few minutes and we have
Mike revealing that he kicked the map
into the creek what what but will
everyone in the movie and in the
audience are thinking what a dumb move
that
it's the logistics of this that are
really telling Mike is not the map guy
as we hear repeatedly through the movie
it's heather who keeps the map in her
back pocket at all times
not too much happier than have to wait a
second so there are only two ways he
could have gotten the map one stolen it
from Heather's back pocket in the middle
of the night where she keeps it or two
gotten it from Josh after he knowingly
kept it during the last map check option
one comes with a bunch of implications
we'll talk about in a minute an option
two would mean that Heather was right
the map was in Josh's possession and
Josh is just lying to her face about it
it also means that Josh is complicit in
losing the map but there are two last
huge details from this section before we
move on as soon as the map goes missing
Heather demands the compass who has the
compass right and before Heather can
hold on to it Josh immediately demands
it away from her in other words their
only other navigational tool is
constantly controlled by and manipulated
by the two guys and not Heather and has
one last nail in the coffin the three
had also decided to just head south
following the creek until they hit
something if years of watching man vs.
wild has taught me anything it's a good
plan it's probably one that Heather got
out of the survivalist book that she had
read prior to this trip the book that we
see at the beginning of the movie and
yet despite everyone agreeing to this
plan that surely would work at a certain
point at 40 to 22 in the movie the guys
just stopped an alter course Heather
asks why they changed up the plan and
gets literally no response they just
decided to and Heather has to be along
for the ride
again what we're seeing is the two guys
subtly manipulating Heather to go in the
direction that they want to go to lead
her around the woods and scare her for a
few days eventually leading her to the
murder house hold on you might say sure
Josh and Mike might be behaving
strangely but what about all those
supernatural things that are happening
to them out in the woods and it's a good
question except for one thing there
aren't any supernatural things that
happen out there in the woods one of the
first big ones is the tent being
surrounded by piles of stones when the
group wakes up and breaks camp
mouki rock piles but Heather herself
admits after the first night that she
sleeps so what's to prevent one of the
guys from building a couple of stone
piles in the night I mean later in the
movie Josh full-on disappears without
anyone in the tent noticing proving that
someone can come and go at will in the
middle of the night without much trouble
speaking of leaving the tent in the
middle of the night when else would Mike
have gotten the opportunity to take the
map and kick it into the creek the
period between us knowing the map exists
and the map going missing is a short
window that takes place overnight what
about that bundle of sticks that shows
up later
well it's just a bunch of sticks that
you can build at home and sure it
contains some hair clothes and teeth
that are implied to be Josh's but it's
not like they're doing DNA testing out
there in the forests of Maryland if this
was indeed a premeditated murder one of
the guys could easily have brought those
things along fun fact even for the movie
itself all the production team did was
ask for a few spare pulled teeth from a
dentist it's just not that hard to get
your hands on human teeth is what I'm
saying
heck I got a collection in my own house
for reasons and how about those sounds
at nights hello well it's worth
mentioning that josh is the first to
hear noises during night one one of them
could have possibly been an Al but the
other one was like a cackling yet does
nothing to document them and no one else
hears them it's also worth noting that
at no point in the movie to the sounds
remotely sound like a cackle and
seriously if he had legitimately heard a
cackle just outside of the tent in a
haunted forest you think he'd be that
chill I heard in my pants there's no way
he's planting the idea of scary sounds
into Heather's head for the sounds in
the forest bleeder in the film remember
that mike is the sound engineer so he'd
definitely have the skills necessary to
rig up a couple audio devices outside
the tent even the compass could be
tampered with if they had a few
neodymium magnets and go figure what's
commonly found in audio equipment like
speakers and headphones neodymium
magnets and who's the sound guy again oh
yeah Mike the guy holding the compass
not the only one who thinks something
weird is going on here again Heather is
suspicious of their behavior flames are
looking alike the devil their job in her
diary on pages 18 21 and 23 three times
specifically calls out either how she
doesn't believe that they're sleeping
through the night or how surprised she
is that they're able to sleep in the
middle of all this scary
life-threatening ghost stuff and she's
100% right it would be weird for anyone
to sleep like that when their lives are
on the line but they know it's not their
lives on the line it's hers so unless
they have to react to some spooky stuff
to keep the illusion alive who can their
Z's on she even gets so close to the
truth making the important observation
in her diary that the strange things
only start to happen when she falls
asleep
what a coincidence that is still there
probably some skeptics out there who
don't believe that Josh and Mike killed
Heather and for you I turn to the most
damning evidence of all the ending it's
pretty ambiguous so let's piece it
together beat by beat Josh goes missing
in a few nights later Heather and Mike
here Josh's screams deep into the woods
Mike who earlier has shown himself to
avoid chasing after noises in the dark
and has the strongest self-preservation
instinct Michael are you saying you're
not coming down I go down leads the
charge out of the tent
pushing Heather to hurry up and follow
in in the pitch-black of the woods again
it's Mike who sees the house and then a
few seconds later goes inside without
hesitating would Heather show some
trepidation about going inside he yells
at her come on in the house once inside
he hears Josh's cries and Mike loudly
shouts that he's headed upstairs to find
him with Heather shortly behind at the
top of the steps he stands there waiting
it's only once Heather's upstairs that
Mike quickly changes his mind
determining that the sounds he's hearing
are apparently from the basement and not
the second floor loudly shouts out again
that he's coming down the stairs
then Russia's down this time without
waiting for Heather and remember this is
all happening in a completely dark house
that mike has allegedly never seen
before
yet he finds the cellar staircase easily
we see Mike go down into the basement
and then the handheld camera is dropped
as most people assume Mike is attacked
by the witch from there Heather catches
up sees Mike standing in the corner gets
attacked her cell and drops her camera
end of movie now this whole sequence is
suspicious for a couple reasons
Mike leading the charge at night is so
outside of his character at this point
especially charging into what is
obviously a murder house hidden inside
the forest he also seems very
comfortable with the layout of said
house even though it's completely dark
and how could Mike mistake sounds coming
from the basement as coming from the top
floor and also why shout where you're
going before you go there unless you're
trying to signal where you're going to
someone else but perhaps most suspicious
of all if he truly got hit by something
in the basement causing him to drop his
camera why would he be well enough to
stand in the corner and not respond when
Heather calls his name in fact after
decades of being tight-lipped about the
end of the movie it's a detail one of
the directors Eduardo Sanchez called out
when he did an AMA on reddit when asked
what really happened at the end
Sanchez doesn't give a clear answer but
remarks about Mike quote why wouldn't he
turn to Heather screams seeming to imply
that he has the ability to turn around
and just chooses not to and it's a
decision that would be difficult to
explain until you consider it was part
of Mike and Josh's plan they would lure
Heather to the house get her to the top
floor as far from the cellar as possible
then Mike would create some separation
by running away that buys them time
where Mike can go stand in a corner that
Heather can see from the bottom of the
stairs distracting her and leaving her
vulnerable to an attack from behind an
attack by Josh blaming it on a
supernatural force that uses Josh's
voice to lure people around the house
brings Mike downstairs hits him on the
head possesses him to put him into the
corner and stand there well it goes
around to hide from Heather so it can
hit her on the head murdering her and
then going back and then killing Mike
again is actually harder to believe a
murder plot where the two guys are
complicit is actually the simplest
solution here but there is one final
piece of evidence that points to
not being supernatural forces and that's
the existence of the movie itself the
fact that the trio's footage was found
indicates that people made it into the
woods found the murder house and got
back home safely without being accosted
by any supernatural beings Blair which
seems oddly selective about protecting
her forest no no she was an excuse for
two young men to team up scare and
eventually kill a girl and be thought
dead giving them the perfect escape for
the perfect plan but hey that's just a
theory a film theory and cuts I dare you
to click on the Blair Witch stick man
hanging in front of you to subscribe for
more creepy theories just in time for
October I'm working on everything from
the ring salad fingers so prepare your
pumpkin spiced flavored food curl up
under a good blanket next to the fire
and get ready for a scary holiday season
click now bot you know what else is
scary stupidity that's why you should
also click right here to visit the
wisecrack channel they've used education
with humor to kill off the Blair Witch
of stupidity alright so that's a really
force metaphor just go and check them
out they'll be research a lot of
episodes that you see here so if you
like film theory there's a good
likelihood that you're gonna have a
scary good time over on their channel if
you haven't checked them out yet carpe
that diem my friends seize the day
so if you'll excuse me we've had a lot
of serious theories lately it's time to
do something fun for a change more on
that in a week